this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
everybody welcome back to the man
carrying thing cinematic universe if you
happen to come from this side of my
channel and you clicked on this video
warning i do talk about books it
literally started out that way i don't
know what kind of sick twisted form this
channel has taken but i'm going to talk
about what i've been reading lately
because i've been reading some fantastic
books but first do you like to get
disturbed you're a big old weirdo well
you're in luck because i'm currently in
the midst of hell i'm in the midst of a
process where and i'm reading 11 or 12
of some of the most disturbing books as
recommended by you all this is going to
be a a video on the channel later on
which brings me to
the road a book that i read for the
first time and was which was mentioned
quite frequently by those of you
recommending disturbing books i get why
and i i didn't really want to read it
because i thought well everyone knows
about the road like i've heard it's
disturbing because it's sad or whatever
but i didn't really want to read it but
so many people recommended it so i was
like okay i'll read it it'll be one of
the early books i read i read for my
disturbing books challenge i will be
posting individual book reviews of each
book that i read throughout the
challenge reviews of each book on my
patreon regardless here's what i think
about the road in broad details um it's
[ __ ] great this was really quick to
get through a little disappointed
because i wasn't that disturbed by the
book maybe that's because i was just
coming off of
this book right here kind of moving and
touching and i've read cormac mccarthy i
love blood meridian and i'd say blood
meridian is far uh it's far more
depressing um i mean there's disturbing
content in both books blood meridian has
way more gore it kind of wallows in
despair in some ways and it's more of a
horror story um whereas this is kind of
like a father-son story that is just
happens to be set in the post-apocalypse
mccarthy is really good at describing
physical detail of
the physical things characters do there
are those who will say maybe it's boring
or repetitive you know the same stuff
happens it's about the father and son
trying to survive you know they're just
walking down the road encountering
certain things bad stuff happens
occasionally a good thing happens very
occasionally it was genuinely touching
like when i got to the end despite how
bleak this book is and bleak the image
of humanity after the end of the world
is there is a kind of undying love that
exists between this father and son and
how even in all of this horror
there's this little spark of hope that's
just really beautiful i mean it's
beautiful it's just beautifully written
i mean it's mccarthy you're getting what
you get from mccarthy the occasionally
archaic words thrown in there out of
nowhere sometimes clunky but also just
like jarringly beautiful i have to
recommend it like if you haven't read it
i think it's time don't read it if
you're in a bad state of mind honestly
although to me it just it felt very
uplifting like to me this felt like a
happy book because like all right we're
talking about the end of the world
everything's you know gone to [ __ ] but
but
there's
this beautiful love that exists between
the father and son it's it's a mythic
tale incredibly well told so check it
out again longer reviews up on the
patreon now in this pile i'm reviewing
only two of the disturbing books because
i've been reading other stuff this is
the book that i've already spent an
entire video on which i recommend you go
check it out because it explores more of
my thoughts on this book but i did read
this the infamous book um people told me
would be disturbing i read it first
because i thought ah this won't be the
most disturbing it disturbed me in a way
where i was kind of like a bit repulsed
by the intentions of the author it had
me hooked for like the first half of the
book and in the second half it was kind
of like oh so this is what's what we're
doing
okay anyways it has some great writing
in it and uh then it just becomes like a
a caricature of itself so self-indulgent
it could have been cut down characters
become unrealistic everything that was
established you know within a certain
sense of realism just is thrown out the
window tonally weird the bad stuff just
keeps happening you know you start to
feel the author as like this hand of god
reaching down and just making bad [ __ ]
go on just for no reason and
to put top everything off i can
absolutely not recommend this to anyone
who's having any kind of mental health
crisis anyone who is uh not feeling well
i would be really worried for someone
who's reading this in a bad frame of
mind you know and who you know that sort
of thing and i i would not want to read
this i'm glad i didn't read this during
like a more depressing time in my life
so
it just didn't hit the landing just no
no i
again watch the video if you want to
know more about
this one next up i'd like to talk about
a book that i think is a genuine
masterpiece this was not for the
disturbing books video i read because i
heard good things about it it won a big
award and and got a bunch of hype it's a
very new book even though the cover
looks old bard case crime they're a
great series you know they publish great
older books tough gritty crime stuff
whatever but a bunch of different things
they publish stephen king occasionally
anyways i like what they do but this is
a new book this came out either this
year or late last year five decembers
this is a crime novel and my god is it
beautiful it takes place over well five
decembers from 1941 through uh 1945
basically goes through the the war i i
do have a caveat for this um the first
hundred or so pages are quite slow uh
they don't they didn't really pull me in
um the writing is fantastic it's short
just cut down to a razor no excess just
like precise like a
finely cut diamond terrific writing i
love that kind of like hard-boiled style
james kestrel is actually the pseudonym
for an author called jonathan moore i
have not read his other work
but um as a fan of this i'm definitely
going to check it out book follows a cop
in honolulu during
1941 two people have been murdered and
he's trying to find the killer it just
happens to be a situation of really bad
timing you know with world war ii
happening now a lot of this a lot is set
up in the book that really has fantastic
payoff so if you feel like the
beginning's a little slow things start
moving so fast there was a point when i
was reading this and um i was reading
the ebook version and was like okay i'll
just check it out i'll read a chapter
you know before bed and then i'm up for
five more hours because i can't stop
reading because i'm going this is insane
when the stuff with the war happens i
don't think that's a spoiler because
it's you know
look at the cover when the stuff with
the war happens you feel so pulled in um
there there's such a sense of danger of
real history occurring all around you
images of horror and beauty more than
anything this book is about just the the
casualty of time there's twists there's
turns my god at the end of it it's just
a heartbreakingly beautiful love story
what else can i say like it's it really
is the whole package i feel like i will
want to reread this one day i can't
recommend it enough but before we get to
our next book a word from our sponsor
skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deep deepen existing passions and get
lost in creativity with skillshare look
it's no secret i'm a big fan of
skillshare they're one of the best and
most consistent sponsors on this channel
and i really love having access to
skillshare i'll mention this again in
case others haven't heard of it one of
my favorite courses is called the
writer's tool kit six steps to a
successful writing habit by simon van
boy i think a lot of us who are writers
uh understand that the the biggest
challenge and hurdle i think for a lot
of people is finding consistent writing
habit and this is just a great practical
series of videos about how to better
your writing practice and become more
consistent and i i found it very useful
there's other great courses on
photography on journalism on on making
videos you can do it in bite size videos
or watch the full course it's curated
specifically for learning meaning there
are no ads they're always launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
skillshare now offers classes in spanish
french portuguese and german the first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description get skillshare for free
for one month thank you skillshare for
sponsoring this video all right back to
it so next up this is a book called
happy for you this is the debut of
claire stanford i was lucky enough to
meet the author she signed this book i
was told about this through one of my
classes and and picked up the book and
and heard that she was going to be
speaking at our school so i went i read
this and it was nice it was it was it
was a good read covers topics of
happiness in the digital age how we try
to quantify happiness and it's kind of
about this character who's trying to
who's working for a tech company there's
some satire here but honestly i didn't
think it was enough it felt a little bit
more like a collection of short stories
or personal essays that were
fantastically written but it didn't have
a kind of forward momentum
until the end of the book you know if
you're into plot heavy books maybe not
the best book for you but as a book that
explores themes of technology happiness
motherhood being asian american anyways
check it out if that sounds interesting
to you next up of course i've been on my
crime fiction spree i've just been
really into crime fiction and uh donald
westlake taken on many different names
uh richard stark is one of his
pseudonyms he wrote the the the parker
series he wrote a lot of comic crime
novels and this was the first one in his
dortmund series probably his most famous
comic crime series and it's called the
hot rock this was turned into a movie in
the 70s i believe with robert redford
but it's very funny i think if you like
terry pratchett you would like donald
westlake it has a very dry sense of
humor that really gets better as you go
along especially since this story is
about you know a crew of criminals
they're trying to pull a heist on a
stone somehow it keeps going wrong and
they have to keep stealing the stone
over and over and over in increasingly
more difficult and ridiculous situations
it gives you time to just kind of
experience the characters through their
dialogue through their actions there's a
lot of funny moments but it's more about
like the humor that derives from the
scenario like it's not just trying to be
clever i don't like books that are just
trying to be clever for clever sake or
trying to just like throw jokes in there
and like look how cute this is i like
comedy in books that kind of come from
the situations there's some
fantastically funny situations in here
the comedy that comes from conflicting
personalities of characters who are out
of their element already got the second
book in the series it's a long series so
there's a bunch of different books but
if you want something that's like a
throwback you know this came out a long
time ago if i can do any good in the
world it is to get people to check out
donald westlake and any of his
pseudonyms so and finally a book that i
actually haven't finished um this was
fun to read for a while but i got kind
of bored it's called la brava as you all
know i'm a big fan of elmore leonard i
think his prose is i mean he writes
characters he writes prose that's
sharper funnier like more realistic than
anything like i've read cuts straight to
the essence and is so detailed in a way
that's like he must have seen that from
someone you know he must have stolen
that from some real person because it's
so like too real to be made up you know
the only issue and i'm starting to see
this as a general trend with elmore
leonard is that he kind of sticks to a
similar story
and plot uh and through a lot of his
books macho
main guy who is trying to catch these
bumbling bad guys you know and he writes
these bad villains and we always see
also from their perspective at how how
incompetent they are and in a way it
lends for comedy but it also relieves
some of the suspense so i think that's
why i found it hard to get through this
full book because whereas i could admire
enjoy the writing from scene to scene
there was not a ton of pressure to go
okay i need to see how this ends i need
to see where this goes if you want to
read a book for its prose for its
characters elmore leonard is great i
think i just wasn't necessarily in the
mood for that at the moment i do feel
like i will finish this well i think
that's everything i am continuing to
read the disturbing book series i'll
keep you all updated on that and
yeah let me know what you all have been
reading or if you have any
recommendations also if you've read
anything that i've recommended on this
channel please let me know i always find
it really nice when when people say
they've actually read something i
recommended even if they didn't like it
but it's nice to to know that it's you
know causing someone to read thank you
for watching as always i hope you have a
lovely day and yeah all right bye bye
[Music]
you